من خان يونس مراسل الجزيره وائل الدحدوح
ينضم الينا خان يونس كانت قد شهدت عدد من
الاستهدافات وايضا نحن في ترقب لتشجيع
جثمان الشهيد علي غالي الذي قتل فجر اليوم
او اغتيل فجر اليوم
[موسيقى]
كرم ابو سالم يونس على مقربه بعد ان كنا
في مدينه حمد حيث اغتيل قائد الوحده
الصاروخيه لصرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي نقل الجثمان من
المستشفى مستشفى ناصر الى منزل اهله وذويه
في هذه المنطقه ومن ثم بعد ان القوا عليه
نظره الوداع ان صح التعبير بالمجاز
باعتبار ان يعني الاستهداف كان مباشرا
وكانت هناك
الجثامين تحولت الى اشلاء نقلت هنا
جثماننين الى هذا المسجد مسجد الرحمه
وقد بدات عمليه بعض المراسم
للبدء في بعض الكلمات والتابين قبيل ان
يرفع اذان الظهر ومن ثم اقامه صلاه الظهر
وبعدها اقامه صلاه الجنازه على روح
الشهيدين علي وشقيقه الذي قضى معه في ذات
الغاره ومن ثم
الانطلاق بمسيره تشييع حاشده الى مثواه
الاخير في مقبره الشهداء بمحافظه غزه كما
تلاحظون
الجثامين مسجاه هنا الجثماني الشهيدين في
هذه الزاويه وبعض المواطنين الفلسطينيين
والشباب يحاولون
التقلصهم تبرك منهم كما يقولون هنا في
قطاع غزه فيما الكلمات على منبر هذا
المسجد تقام كما تلاحظون كلمه تلوى كلمه
كلمه من قيادات في الجهاد الاسلامي وفي
حركه حماس وفي القيادات الموجوده
والمتواجده هنا في هذا المسجد حتى يتم رفع
اذان الظهر ومن ثم اقامه صلاه الظهر وصلاه
الجنازه على الشهيد بطبيعه الحال هذه
المحافظه شهدت استهدافات كثيره لكن كان
الاستهداف الابرز هو هذا الاستهداف الذي
اودى بحياه قائد الوحده الصاروخيه في
سرايا القدس علي ابو غالي
وشقيقه فضلا عن شخص ثالث ايضا سيشيع
جثمانه الى مثواه الاخير ولكن في محافظه
رفح حيث يسكن هذا الاستهداف حسب كل
الروايات وش الاعيان والاوساط الفلسطينيه
تحدثوا عن ان هذا الاستهداف انما هو تكرار
لسيناريو اتبعته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وطائراتها في في اغتيال القاده الثلاثه
الكبار من سرايا القدس في باكوره هذه
الموجه من التصعيد عندما استهدفت ثلاثه
شقق سكنيه ايضا في مناطق متفرقه من قطاع
غزه احداها كان في المحافظه المجاوره
لمحافظه خان يونس حيث نتواجد الان وهي
التي استهدفت جهاد الغنام امين سر المجلس
العسكري لسرايا القدس في حين استهدفت
الغراء الغارتين الاخرىتين قائد المنطقه
الشماليه وايضا احد القيادات في العمل في
الضفه الغربيه
وبالتاكيد هو هذا الاستهداف هو الذي تسبب
في
كل هذه الصور وكل هذه التد والاحداث
والتطورات وبالتالي هذه المدينه او هذه
المحافظه التي نتواجد فيها ما تزال تتعرض
الى بعض الاستهدافات قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قبل فتره وجيزه من الان
استهدفت اراضي زراعيه ولكن في مناطق تبعد
عن المكان التي نتواجد فيه اي في المناطق
الشرقيه لخان يونس وفي المناطق الشرقيه
تحديدا في منطقه القراره الى الشمال الشرق